everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over a very sound open EMS the
semi Slav you've seen it all levels of
chest especially at high levels of chess
and it starts with pawn to e4 pawn to d5
very common for high levels of chess
pawn to c4 again this is the Queen's
game it in action and then pawn to e6
now again opposed to the the normal slob
defense where black actually tries to
get his LightSquared Bishop out of the
pawn chain in the semi Slav he actually
opts to bring his pawn to e6 first now
why it's going to continue with Knight
to c3 again simple development move from
white trying to control the center and
get his minor pieces involved this
through the game black's going to play
Knight to f6 again same thing simple
development move again trying to control
these light squares in particular this
square here on e4 why it's going to
continue again with Knight to f3 simple
development and black is going to play
pawn to c6 so right away I want to take
a look at a few things here from black
as you can see if it's going to be
really hard for black anytime soon to
get this light squared Bishop into the
game obviously we do have this pawn
structure here with this pawn on e6
blocking the way more than likely unless
this pawn goes away as far as a exchange
variation then more than likely this
Bishop is going to be coming to b7 or a
6 trying to get some counter play
attacking the King sat on these long
diagonals at the same notion more than
likely we're going to be bringing our
Knight to d7 from black any time you
bring your pawn to c6 that usually
indicates that you're going to be
bringing your Knight to d7 what that
also means is that you're going to be
bringing your Queen into the action more
so more times than not along this
diagonal right here yeah it's usually
not going to be coming up again because
you will have your knight here on D 7 so
you may see you know Queen to c7 or you
may want to be more active with Queen to
b6 or Queen to a5 depending on the
variation now if we look from White's
perspective why it's really trying to
control the center of the board as you
can see blacks trying to
play a kind of passive at the beginning
trying to get some counter played later
on into the game white really has a few
options he can get his dark squared
bishop involved into the game obviously
nothing right now is defending this pawn
here on c4 so he could opt for in early
e3 which is actually the mainline but if
you look at this variation you can also
see that this dark square bishop is now
locked in so he does have to decide if
he wants to go ahead and play III or if
he wants to go ahead and get his dark
squared Bishop out of the pawn chain
before he wants to defend this pawn here
on c4 so a lot going on just in the the
opening of the semi Slav a lot to talk
about
during this video so just want to kind
of give you all some background before
we kind of dive in to some of the main
variations that you'll see the main line
typically continues with one of two
things it's either pawn to e3 or Bishop
down to g5 so first thing we're going to
talk about is pawn to e3 again really
opening up the door so this pawn here on
c4 is defended but as we can see this
bishop here on c1 is also going to have
a much harder time to come out because
this pawn here on e3 is blocking it now
from here black usually is going to
continue as we talked about before with
Knight to d7 and then black has two
different options more than likely he's
going to bring his Bishop to d3 and then
black is going to exchange his pawn here
on c4 and the bishops going to take with
his bishop here on c4 obviously white
wants to develop all his pieces try to
control the center of the board and then
castle on the King side but you can see
here once the bishop comes to d3 he's
basically wasting a move after he does
this variation right here so a lot of
times if a white player assumes that his
opponent is going to take this pawn here
on c4 he'll do kind of an in-between
move and go ahead and try to develop one
of his extra pieces so instead of
playing at Bishop to d3 first he will
play Queen to c2 now if white were to
have his pawn leave on c4 now he can
take with his Bishop on C
for but he does also have this Queen
here on c2 just one extra move closer to
all his pieces being developed obviously
he needs to get his dark squared bishop
involved into the game and then white
can castle on either the king side or
the Queen's now there's always very very
important that you understand the main
line in any variation just to make sure
that if you're ever confused it's
typically a good notion to stick with
the main line to make sure you don't
fall for any traps and the main line
does continue with Bishop to d3 as we
talked about before and after black
captures on c4 and white recaptures on
c4 now black is going to play pawn to b5
again one of the themes that you'll see
in the semi Slav is yes at the beginning
black does play semi passive trying to
develop all his his pieces trying to get
ready to counter-attack
but again the theme that you'll see is
you need to counter-attack if you just
kind of say back the entire game why
it's going to pretty much dominate the
center of the board develop all his
pieces and then he's going to crush
black so you definitely need to have
some counter play typically in the semi
slob it's going to be on the Queen side
at least in the mainline variation so it
starts with pawn to b5 now white does
have a few options here but the typical
one is going to be to bring it back to
d3 this is the main line and then black
has two options from here his first
option which has had a lot of success on
the GM level is to bring his pawn to a6
getting ready to thrust forward with his
pawn to c5 again really trying to break
up the center of the board white really
has a firm grasp on these dark squares
on the center of the board obviously he
can't come right away and just play pawn
to c5 because he does have his pawn here
on b5 hanging so he does kind of have
this a6 move to kind of defend this pawn
on b5 and then he's going to start a
push forward with his pawn on c5
obviously he does have this night here
on b7 and he also has this bishop here
on FA both being a key defender on this
c5 square now black doesn't have to play
a six and then play this push
to see five he does have two other
options he could go ahead and bring
excuse me he could bring his bishop if
he wanted to to be seven he could also
bring it to a six more than likely
you'll see it come to be seven here so
again as we talked about before since
this e six move was played early on more
than likely the LightSquared bishop is
not going to be played on this side but
again we are going to play it on this b7
square black will later on try to thrust
forward with his pawn to c5 and really
open up this door so this LightSquared
bishop can really get involved into the
game another variation that you
definitely want to be aware of again as
we talked about before from here white
usually plays Bishop to d3 or if he is
expecting this pawn to come here on c4
and capture a lot of times you'll see
that in between move of Queen to c2 now
there's this cat-and-mouse game white
really thinks that blacks going to take
on c4 so black and say hey actually I'm
not going to take on c4 instead I'm
going to play Bishop to d6 again
centralizing this dark square Bishop
getting him involved into the game and
really trying to just develop our pieces
so black can castle on the King side and
really try for a counter attack the
problem with this is white actually has
a very famous gambit that conspire I've
used against deep Junior back in the
early 2000s I say that only because a
lot of players when they hear a game if
they automatically think hey this is
just some dubious move but this is
actually a very very solid move and the
move is actually pawn to g4 and if you
look at it it kind of looks funky but
what it does if you can look at black
side right here it's going to be really
hard for black any time in the near
future to castle on the King side
obviously black can cast on the King
side right away but it's going to be
very easy for black obviously all he has
to do or excuse me for white all he has
to do is move his bishop he could just
move his bishop to d2 he could castle on
the Queen side and as you can see if
this pawn falls on g4 or even if the
pawn comes
you know c4 to take it's going to be
very hard y can really push up the board
here wants black castles on the King set
and white castles on the Queen side he's
going to be putting a lot a lot of
pressure on the King side of black so
it's going to be very hard for black to
cope with this obviously black would
really like to castle on the Queen side
but white just has too much under
control and black just doesn't have
enough room to get all of his pieces
into the action and castle on the Queen
side so again if you're playing this
cat-and-mouse game and you do play you
know Bishop to d6 or if you're white and
you see this and you play this
in-between move of Queen to c2 and then
your opponent plays Bishop to d6
basically saying hey I'm not ready to
take this pawn on c4 I'm going to kind
of make you waste another move instead
of playing anything fancy just play this
nice little gambit of pawn to g4 if it
worked for Kasparov and it's good enough
for him I'm sure he's looked at it
longer than any of us have and so I say
I say go ahead and knock it out because
he was pretty good at chess so
definitely keep this in the back of your
mind while you're playing the semi Slav
defense now a lot of white players when
they do play against the sims lob
defense one of the things that they
really have a hard time with is getting
their dark bishop involved into the game
obviously a lot of times in the mainline
we see this pawn to e3 and then the rest
of the game they just don't use their
luck they're dark-squared bishop here
from c1 now again is if you've seen any
of my videos before you know I always
preach on the fact that it's not about
the size of the army it's about the size
of the army that you have in the fight
so it doesn't matter if you are up in
material if you're not using all your
guys it really doesn't mean anything so
a lot of white players are actually
advocating bringing our the bishop down
to g5 really getting the white the dark
square bishop here on g5 active before
the the pawn chain solidifies here on e3
and he says you know what I will even
trade off my bishop for the night here
on f6 it doesn't really matter this
night here on f6 is going to be much
more active than the dark squared Bishop
than if it just stays back on c1 and it
gets blocked off by e3
so this is kind of the reasoning
obviously these are the two main lines
is III and then the the more and more
popular the Bishop to g5 now black does
have a few variations from here that you
will see you may see it coming to the
Cambridge Springs defense which a lot of
players really like to play and that is
Knight to d7 and then white can now play
his pawn to e3 again solidifying that
pawn chain and then from here black is
going to play Queen to a5 again this is
the Cambridge Springs defense if you are
familiar with it
very solid from black now black also has
a few other options he could always play
you know the Orthodox defense he could
play h6 and just kind of see what white
wants to do he could always exchange
here and then he could bring his queen
up to f6 here or we could get some very
very complicated lines and those really
come from if black plays pawn takes on C
fours you can see right away black is up
in material and from here blacks going
to really try to play pawn to b5 to
solidify his extra pawn here on c4 from
here White's going to play e4 again this
is very important to note white gave up
his pawn on c4 but what is he gain in
return
he gained the center of the board so he
now has a pawn on e4 he also has a pawn
on d4 pretty much just dominating the
center of the board it's going to be
very very hard for black to cope with
this right away and as you can see kind
of the mainline variation from this it
just gets kind of crazy I kind of like
crazy so hopefully you do too as well
but it continues with pawn to b5 again
we really need to solidify this pawn
here on c4 from black we do have a small
advantage right now so if we don't hold
on to that since white does have center
control you never want to be down the
material and be down in you know
development and center control but from
here white actually has
some moves where he can gain back
material he can play pawn to e5
obviously right now this Knight is
pinned down to the Queen here on d8
so this Knight is going to fall black
does have the option you can always come
to h6 say hey if you're going to take my
night here on f6 I'm going to take your
Bishop here on g5 Bishop can be kicked
back to h4 the pawn can now come to g5
basically saying hey I'm going to take
you and the knight can actually come in
and sacrifice and after we take the
knight and the bishop comes back to d5
Black's kind of in the same spot that he
was before as you can see this is really
getting kind of crazy
this Knight is going to fall from this
pawn here on e5 the King side from black
is completely jacked up but you can also
see that white really doesn't have as
strong of a center as he did before it's
going to just be wild and crazy' lines
from here so if you come across this yes
definitely if he plays you know Bishop
to g5 you can take this pawn on c4 just
be ready that you know right away
White's really going to have control of
the center of the board obviously once
he takes you know on f6 he's really only
going to have this pawn here on d4 but
it is definitely going to be a crazy
game so if you don't like crazy games
definitely don't take this pawn here on
c4 instead go for something like the
Cambridge Springs defenses we talked
about or you could always go with the
with the Orthodox defense but if you
like crazy hey go for that as well so
the semi Slav offense hopefully you guys
enjoy this video again very very solid
defense from black many many variations
for you to equalize with your opponent
and have very many attacking lines keep
in mind that you do want to be
aggressive typically on the Queen side
you don't want to stay back too much and
make sure that your lines when you're
playing are on point and you have
everything exactly playing as you should
or allows your opponent is just going to
completely run over you so hopefully you
guys enjoy the video if you haven't
checked out the website awhile WWE chess
website com leave some comments let me
know how it went and I will see you
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching